alright let me talk about saying that is
not controversial at all that doesn't
bring up high emotions that everybody
agrees on that there's no conspiracy
theories nobody's freaking out over
that's right I'm talking about gamergate
okay so if you're not familiar with
gamergate i just became familiar with
gamergate in the last couple weeks cuz i
keep seeing the hashtag on twitter right
i see some videos on youtube and i've
read some articles about it's hard to
figure out what it is it's a lot of
things it's a lot of things depending on
who you are depending on what articles
reading what videos you're watching and
basically it was a movement to sort of
the gamers themselves this community of
gamers pretty much realized that there
was collusion between the game creators
and the magazines that were reviewing
them too they were incentivizing
sometimes but higher ratings it's a
whole big mess but basically the
community of gamers wanted so there to
be some sort of uh some rules around the
gaming business which basically seems
fair then it got whole big mess in terms
of misogyny and people were attacking
each other on Twitter and they were
claiming girls were slots and all this
awful stuff than they were daxing which
is when you release all this kind of
personal information about people
usually done on Twitter and people
attacking each other then they felt that
the mainstream media wasn't dealing with
it fairly anyway I'm reading all this
stuff and I thought all right well maybe
I can do something honest because it
seems like the gamers feel like they've
been treated unjustly by the media but
maybe I'll do a video on it I tweeted
outside and I got a bajillion responses
people started yelling at me immediately
for even wanting to cover it some people
then but then they all fight not you
know literally hundreds response down
the way and this is one of these things
where I realized sometimes we all want
to think that we can sort of get a story
and understand the story and I want to
think that I can sort of read enough
about saying that I can understand it
and explain it in a kind of simple way
this is one of these things that just
goes beyond everything it is truly a
rabbit hole of information and this
information and one of these things
where you can't make everybody happy I
really at this point the more I know
about it the less i actually know that's
the point that it's gotten to it me um
so I'm really curious uh what you guys
think so this is one of those things
where I do you want you to come
down below and let me know what you
think what is the truth can anyone sum
it up in a two-minute video or can
someone sum it up in a paragraph to
paragraph I have no idea it is deep
people but the truth is out there